The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah,
he's going to smell in the blood.
he's good.
He knows a lot of people.
I know.
That's one thing I'm not good at.
I have,
I'm working on that.
Mark was telling me other day like I want to start finish people with the hands.
Like you had so many fights where you couldn't,
but you hit a guy with a condom on and you've take a shot like the guy be right.
You just don't see it.
Instead of key punching them,
you as shoot,
he stopped punching your chute on him.
It's was like I hate guys are combos and like when I go to the boss and you're
like Bro,
you box like you a boxer but you go into your fight and you box just to get your
take downs.
But that's because I'm a wrestler.
I can box.
I don't have to but I will.
Do you think there's a worry though when you're trying to finish fights versus
just trying to fight your best?
I think guys should just fight the best and if a finished comes at comps,
I'm of the opinion that I'm of the opinion that when people make big mistakes,
and I wouldn't discourage anybody from going crazy if someone likes to go crazy,
they like to fight wild.
Hey man,
that's you.
That's your style.
That's how you express yourself.
Nothing wrong with that.
But if I was going to give some advice,
they said,
what should I do?
I want to have a long career as a professional.
Let's say fight your best.
Don't worry about the outcome,
just fight your best.
And if you fight your best and if you connected,
someone gets hurt and you put them away,
that's great.
But if you just win,
that's great to just fight your best.
The more,
the more you can do what you can technically and take as little damage as
possible.
That's a good fight.
And this,
like I said,
that's almost the OSP fight.
Mark said it like you just gotta smothers,
got whole camp,
he's got that good kit and they had the Osp fi and GM volante the two fights and
mark called only thing that I can get knocked out way.
He said,
well Gee,
I'm blind to the only thing this guy can knock you out with his overhand right.
He says you got to bring that Jab right back after you've got a good job of
bringing your hands back.
Cause he's times that overhand.
Right?
So smooth and even in between rounds like you eat over here,
right?
I know it's not hurting you but only takes one.
It takes one.
Keep that hand up,
keep that hand up.
And sure enough to this day he say,
remember I told you over here.
Right?
And then with Osp is like only thing I can get you it is that,
hey that left kick.
If you stay close to them,
keep the pressure,
keep them on occasion when he's down he stand up,
bring them back down.
Don't listen to the fans.
People are going to boot it.
Get,
get to your head and make you want to strike.
Trying to get in that fight.
That's what they want to see.
But we just try and get the win.
Don't go right and keep pressure.
Do not go right and keep pressure.
Have you watched that fight?
The whole two rounds.
Pressure and not going right.
Going left,
put into the case,
taken back,
keep them down in the case.
He stand up,
bring them back.
Third around.
I took him down,
he popped out when I was against the case.
I can remember hearing people say,
Oh,
let's tear it up and fight and stand up and fight.
And I backed away for a second,
started moving like God almost play from the outside a little bit.
And I went right right into the head kick and I was like,
you know when I came,
first thing mark sat in the back,
I wrote,
you look phenomenal.
You just went right.
Like you look great.
Everything was beautiful.
That fight,
that was your breakthrough fight.
He you,
you just went right.
But we're going to go back.
You're going to do better.
I know you will.
And now it's just like after that,
like I said,
I went to drama.
It was like fuck what the fancy,
we went into France.
But like you said when you and Sean like I listened to before and you say I
believe the chief you,
I beat this but you don't hear my name is because I'm not trying to do this
stuff that's exciting anymore.
I'm just winning and my style and excited.
But that's cause you're not a mixed martial arts fan.
You're a fan of a knockout or you're a fan of some fancy stuff.
They talking in Johnny Walker up.
This is Ms. Johnny Walker hasn't shown mixed martial.
Oh Shit.
He's shown fancy stuff that knock people out.
It looks great.
Yes.
But just like Anthony Smith and all those guys,
when they get in front of somebody like John Jones and you can't hit them with
that one punch,
what are you going to do?
You know what I mean?
So that's thing I say right now I'm not fighting.
He said,
when are you going to fight?
I don't know,
but I'll be ready cause I can do everything.
Yeah.
We were just talking about Johnnie Walker.
He's in surgery now who he had to go through surgery for shoulder cause that,
that celebration,
that celebration was just so crazy.
He wins Eba beets or corn off with a beautiful time knee.
Perfect flying knee looks fantastic and then drops to the ground just playing
around and blows his fucking shoulder out.
It was crazy.
Yes,
the gang or anything can happen.
You never knew his hand injury.
What happens like that?
It's like God damn man,
you're so promising.
Um,
he's a,
he's a mean.
What,
what gets people excited when people finish fights,
right?
But People Kao People.
And so a lot of times people try to lean towards that.
But if that's not your style,
you know,
you should,
you should fight the way your f if I was in your corner,
first of all,
I'd say listen to Mark Henry,
Mark Henry knows everything.
And then second of all,
let's say don't change Shit,
man.
What you're doing is perfect.
Just just fight.
The way you're fighting,
the way you're fighting is just you winning.
You know,
you when you're,
you're,
I just think that it should be what it should be emphasized always to fight the
best.
You can fight intelligently and you got to decide and everybody has to decide
when is it time to take a risk?
When is it time to close the distance?
When is it time to put pressure on someone and and throw yourself into the fire
to try to get a finish.
And if you just think you should just fight technically.
Look man,
fucking Floyd Mayweather has done that most of his career,
especially like later on when he was pretty boy Floyd.
Early on in his career,
he's tried to knock a lot of guys out,
but later on in his career and most of his big fights,
like with Pacquiao and a lot of the guys,
he does wins.
He just wins and he makes more money than anybody.
Just wins
interests me and my mind.
I know exactly.
I'll tell you when I get in this barn,
no spoilers might want to work on things.
You know,
every,
every side they going to spot me and my wife's Josh,
like what are we working on today?
We're going to try to work on putting a little more emphasis on the punches and
not shoot right away,
a blah,
blah,
blah on the ground.
More ground and pound.
Don't worry about that.
UGC submissions just hit this,
this and this.
When it's come time to fight,
when the lights come on Saturday night and Joe or Bruce buffer in there and you
sit at the side,
it's a whole different game plan.
I know what I can do.
I know what's right and that's why I get into those spots and like I tell my
stuff,
take a shot.
It's muscle memory,
but I hit him.
He put his hands up and he stopped the legs wide open court.
Oh,
the NCAA.
All American NCAA finalist.
Why we're not shooting.
I take them down.
Exactly and have you look at my last three fights.
I feel like going back and watching them,
those,
you can't say I'm one side because Ilir everybody will know where he can wrestle
at lear.
Lear is way more powerful and better wrestler he works for,
for uh,
whatever where he's from Albanian world team.
He couldn't take me down and I was struck him,
you know,
you went to glow.
Like I'll go over the finish and introduce who got cord goes to ground him.
It's over and you can not Cory out.
I was struggling.
I'll rested up and got them in out and had him Saiga.
I had him,
he had his back.
I had every position on him.
So you can't say I don't have Jujitsu,
I don't have Russ and I don't have striking cause near and impact comes.
Everybody thought he was the NCAA.
Do you want all American?
This is,
he beat DC at OTC.
Hit begs on gonna kill quarter in wrestling.
Stop.
Just take down and set the record with 13 take downs on him who had the record
at 11 it's like,
I don't understand the fans.
Everybody got something to say.